in honor of their one year anniversary
mochina Henderson has a special
promotion planned and Jillian joins us
live again to show us what they are
cooking up hi Jillian
hi Mercedes yes we are cooking in the
kitchen back here and the slogan at
mochina is not your typical donut did I
get that right more than just enough
more than just a donut hey it's not your
typical donut either right Matthew
thanks for having us here can you tell
us what makes your donut special uh so
it's actually made with a Mochi flower
there's no dry active yeast in these so
the best thing about these they're 99
gluten free
um so those for those who are gluten
intolerant most of our Donuts are very
gluten friendly this one I'm about to
glaze these Donuts are ready to go this
is our passion fruit glaze real passion
fruit in here and some hibiscus syrup
that we make as well I can smell it from
here it smells amazing very tropical so
it's always the same technique we're
going to twirl it around and then nice
and easy there's our passion fruit donut
so we make all these glazes from scratch
right in-house and all our fruit glazes
have real fruit puree in them so all
made right here in-house uh very good if
I worked here I would eat these every
day all right let's make our way over
here because you guys have even more
stuff on the menu this machine is really
cool let's make this house we make our
milk tea bobas this one I'm going to
make really quick is going to be our
Brown Sugar by Far and Away the most
popular one this is our brown sugar
syrup that we drizzle inside and then
our brown sugar Boba so if you like
brown sugar you will be coming to the
right spot and uh nice and easy brown
sugar Boba just a tiny bit of ice and
we'll be ready to finish our drink here
and then we only use organic A2 whole
milk for this one as well and then we
also make a really cool cheese foam a
little bit of heavy cream cream cheese
turns into a nice froth here so this is
our house made cheese foam wow I've
never heard of cheese is really cool you
can add it to any drink not just the
brown sugar one and then here's the the
most fun part is going to be sealing up
the machine so we make all these drinks
to order and we seal it up right here in
the store and here's our special machine
oh my gosh and finished product here
here's our brown sugar look at that this
looks amazing before we wrap up to uh
look away I'm taking this with me this
looks so good but let me tell you we
promised you were gonna take a bite tell
us what you have here this is one of
your most popular menu items yes and
then so not only do we have the donuts
and the milk tea we have our um our rice
hot dogs it's made with a rice flour
batter so it's light and fluffy in the
middle but it's crunchy on the outside
and this one in particular has extra
crispy french fries on the outside mango
habanero House made honey mustard a
little bit of grated Parmesan and uh
this is one of our most popular best
sellers oh it looks so good I know
you're gonna take a bite really good
we'll take a little bite because it is
really good and I'm hungry but before we
take a bite tell us about the promotion
really oh yes eight news come by uh
anytime between now and Sunday
um we're giving away free donuts anybody
who's seen us on the news uh all through
Sunday and we have all these flexible
flavors and uh yeah just come on by
thank you so much thank you so much guys
Wendy was telling me those are chewy and
very good right we like those all right
Deck the Halls if you want some donuts
and then you can have some beer with it